rodeado de sus abogados y policías
antimotines
el presidente peruano pedro castillo
camino de manera sorpresiva desde
palacio de gobierno hasta la fiscalía
para responder un interrogatorio sobre
una denuncia por presunto tráfico de
influencias en el proceso de ascensos en
las fuerzas armadas y policiales una de
las cinco investigaciones en su contra
en declaraciones a la prensa el
mandatario insistió en su inocencia
primero a decir que no soy parte y no
formo ninguna red criminal
eso lo he dicho el día de hoy a la
fiscal de la nación y le dicho que voy a
demostrar en cualquier espacio aquí allá
y donde sea mi inocencia yo no cometí a
nadie a nadie robado a nadie matado
castillo también se enfrenta a
investigaciones por presunto tráfico de
influencias en la compra de combustible
por parte de la empresa estatal
petroperú corrupción y colusión agravada
en un proyecto de obra pública un caso
conocido como el consorcio puente tarata
plagio en su tesis doctoral y
obstrucción a la justicia en la
destitución de un ministro del interior
a pesar de que el mandatario niega estar
implicado en casos de corrupción en perú
se corren los rumores de que estaría
buscando asilo político por lo que el
congreso le negó permiso para viajar a
colombia para la investidura de gustavo
petro con 67 votos en contra el pleno
del congreso no aprobó el proyecto de
resolución legislativa 27 41 que
autoriza el presidente de la republica a
salir del territorio nacional del 6 al 8
de agosto de 2022
castilla es el primer presidente peruano
investigado por la fiscalía mientras
esté en funciones casi todos los ex
presidentes de las últimas décadas
tienen problemas con la justicia